[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah is wendy williams still popping
yeah she just had a movie on lifetime
she did yeah
about her about her but does that mean
she's popping if you haven't i don't
know
hey she's popping you guys are talking
about her yeah there you go well i was
just curious whatever
that's all she wanted right there
is wendy williams popping she is right
now
she is she just popped well she made
headlines because she said she hooked up
with method man
met the man a few years ago yeah a few
years ago yeah yeah
met the man i see why that'd be a
problem yeah yeah right
hey [ __ ] you wear size 14. ugh
swole and then dr dre yeah can i tell
you something what's up doug
busta rhymes is the biggest dude i've
ever
like like no really one time at the
comedy store
i forgot the the the i think it was
trent i forgot whoever the one of the
door guy park
guys he comes up to me and the park guy
just pulled up and he goes
he goes man i just got into it with
busta rhymes
and i said what because rusty was trying
to park you know
and he let and he was good he and your
door guys it's a racket you know
yeah they they make more money than the
comics by far it's
crazy yeah you know just like selling
booths selling parking
yeah he was trying to hustle he was
trying to get a hundred dollars out of
the bus to the park
in the parking lot right and so it
turned into a thing so he's retelling me
the story
and up walks buster on it's like is that
[ __ ] telling you about how he
and so i went like this
no you know he was just telling me how
he made a big mistake yeah with you
actually yeah trying to help him out
yeah you you're the guy yeah yeah
but this dude is huge really okay
i'm telling you he shook my hand and one
of his fingers was
like this like that was one of his
fingers and i was like this is the
biggest dude i've ever seen friends i
didn't know that i was like he could
kill us
both yeah man he is a [ __ ] let me see
method man too
it's like you can't tell that don't show
no you need to put a stapler next to him
or something
it was his birthday the other day he
posted look how big
let me tell you what's happening i'll
tell you what happens when you get into
your 40s
hello i'm right here all this you don't
know you need to take care of your
health
until you need to take care of your
health okay okay and when you get to
this age is when you start
this is when you start going vegan when
you start eat going
paleo when you go like i need to start
working out like i always say
i say at night i turn into a hogwarts
potion master
because at night i'm like ginger root
tumeric
[Applause]
you that's when you gotta be like oh i
gotta go to sleep at eleven i gotta wake
up at eight i gotta like
this is what happens yeah so you start
because you know you don't you know
it's like young people that are into
fitness and taking care of themselves
good for them you will live longer you
will be healthier you know because the
people that haven't been doing that
they get because now we don't bounce
back method man's knees hurt
hell yeah madam man stayed out all night
one night trying to drink cavacio and
[ __ ] he woke up like
i am gonna die you know and then the
doctor said something and then here's
another thing too what happens
even when you get in shape you go to the
doctor
and they're like yeah your blood sugar
is bad but i but i love it
no that's like honest that's real [ __ ]
yes
happened to me with my blood pressure
yeah man yeah no matter what i was like
but my wrestling heart rate's 45 they're
like
yeah we don't give a [ __ ] your your
blood pressure's through the roof
mountains yeah
so that's when you start to really start
to like look at so i'm not surprised
that i see someone
and then the thing too in this country
unfortunately you know somebody with
money
you have better chance to like take care
of yourself and be healthy
because you have the resources to do
that yeah i can't get expensive too yeah
plus i also think i don't know when he
started his health journey but also with
covet too like
one thing we know about covid the people
who are in shape who get it
you know more likely to survive like
that's one way to be coveted
vitamin d is another thing that people
you don't you don't know until you get
older that that's important
you know i mean that's like the half the
country's vitamin d deficient and don't
even know it
and vitamin d does a lot i started
taking vitamin d nails growing fast
[Applause]
i was like god damn all right fatty just
looking great yeah
where was this turn [ __ ] early
yeah but you still how do you 29 yeah
yeah yeah
like yeah like people like rh brag about
like yeah we you know we finished [ __ ]
like that but like for someone
like in their 40s yeah uh when they brag
when they brag about it
this is a big but but me and jay were
making fun of
really everybody in the group chat
because how impressed you guys are by
225 yeah like that's our
that's our warm-up i know i know because
you come you come from football
you know jay doesn't know he's just a
big thick dude so jay's like dude
he'll be like malik tells me 10 times
like look
demon warm up 20. well jay is not an
ectomorph again i got a try
thick dude yeah yeah i'm 190 right now
here i i don't know 90. one night
why you looking away
look at that one night my two arms and
this leg
what i was gonna say to eric is uh we're
on the road in tampa this past weekend
we're scrolling through [ __ ] to watch
and workaholics was on there with uh
[ __ ] love we were crazy and uh with a
movie we were doing a movie
that was my question for you are you are
you in the movies movie i mean
how could you not
it will be some hateful [ __ ] out on the
internet
but it is what it is you know because
they told me about it so they mean i
don't think they telling me about it you
know like adam said i got some great
news and i was like
either your girl is pregnant or we doing
a workaholics movie that's what i said
to him yeah
oh wow so uh yeah so i mean i'm not
surprised
that show's so good my bro you know i
never had a regular job with my brother
my brother works in an office
and he's like the reason why this show
carried on for so long he's like bro
that's how it is in those offices he's
like all these personalities and like
the relationships he's like that's why
that show's so big yeah my brother's
like that's exactly how it is well i
love that it's kind of like re like
what it's going to also do is make
people be like well let me check that
show out and then like you know it's all
it's true
it was like seven seasons just when uh
that news came out i got all these
messages and i was like damn how does
this
how do you deal with that because you
killed it though you know so what was it
seven seasons yeah seven seven years
well the episode one of the episodes we
watched in tampa was the one where it's
mainly you it's you and that
old guy yeah
yeah it was in korean time yeah and you
got kidnapped and over the briefcase
i keep telling them like for this movie
let's do something from montez that we
can spin off
because you're a character when you're
when you have a good like amount of air
time where it's like [ __ ] yeah like when
you're on there i'm a hell yeah
and a solid character but it's always
about them though you know what i mean
it's just always been about them even
when we're shooting the show it's always
about them like you know so me and big
guy bill we would always
have this joke instead it'd be like we'd
be like so what's the over under on our
takes for when the camera turns on us
yeah two and a half would be that
like when it's on them it's like single
on adam single on blake single honduras
double on adam endures
let's uh you know solo on it so they we
do like 15 things this way then they
turn it around
two two takes
that's all about them yeah that's a big
ass show man yeah yeah
big show yeah man so it was like uh
you know just something the synergy of
like those guys they have something so
they're doing a podcast right now
and i think that i think that they
realize man we're just you know
we have our individual things but we're
just better together you know there's
only one only one of them's actual stand
up right
yes it's only adam only adam's to stamp
the other two are just yeah straight up
actors yeah yeah they're acting they're
good they're like improv
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they're
does those kind of performers
but then like kyle you know he's a big
big director now he directs you know he
directed murder mystery that's how i got
in it
you know oh [ __ ] yeah he recommended me
to sandler and then uh
sandler looked at my stuff and then i
got the part you know [ __ ] yeah i didn't
know
you know yeah it was real simple then
he's like and then he told me about it i
remember
kyle calls me he's like yeah man you
know uh i got this thing's in the works
and i was like okay it's in the works
yeah everyone you know what i mean
everybody's in the works
call me when it's time you know then i
was doing this like independent movie
and then he calls like bro uh that's
right
you know and i kind of brushed it off
like well i'm already doing this other
thing man
so then when he hits you back again he's
like sandler's yelling at us
yeah he's like he's yelling at us you
know you got to come so we worked it out
then i flew to montreal
and you know was this recent no this was
one before murder mystery you know so
it's like
then we go i get there and then like you
know i meet him
adam yeah because we do a run through
because it was an action scene
you know like we're and we had this long
walk and talk
you know and it was great you know like
the the scene and then we like foil a
robbery
and all this kind of stuff so he wanted
to do the blocking and all this stuff so
then that night
the the night um i know actually before
i met him okay so we go
we do a blocking and then that then kyle
goes i gotta go to dinner
all right i gotta go to this cast dinner
and i was like well i'm gonna be it you
know i didn't
that's the look of my face i was like
damn i'm just a really a glorified extra
right
then an hour later he calls me get over
here you know they're asking for you you
know
so i get to the dinner right and like
it's one of those things i walk in the
room and then the whole place
looks you know what i'm saying yeah you
know and then it was like the the stars
were here and then like the other people
over here and then i make a joke i'm
like i'm at the riffraff table you know
so then he says jimmy which is the
character of my character you know
he's like oh jimmy's here you know what
i mean and then like then i look at this
table
here's jennifer aniston here's the dude
from uh
the the dude to play gaston in uh the
new beauty and the beast movie oh he's a
great actor right right and i go oh [ __ ]
beauty and the beast and then
adam shannon goes yeah man it's like
your [ __ ] oh
yeah that says it so that made me feel
oh that's because
that's what i mean like oh that's
[ __ ] awesome you know he's like yeah
that's a good bit
that he's that that's a good bit that he
saw yeah right so he's like yeah
you know what i heard this gives me a
hug you know what i mean i was like oh
did you soak it in
yeah i'm light skinned chandler right
now
you know what i mean oh [ __ ] you smell
good
she's so good she's good
she's so great she's very nice and then
we just had we had this great dinner and
that was that you know what i mean and
then we just filmed the scenes and it
was like it was really great to like you
know
be doing this scene with him and then
what happened was they cut this scene
they cut the because they wanted to
change the beginning of the movie
so they cut them so they cut that so
they were like we need to redo it so i
get a call
eric we need to redo this scene and then
they're adding me to another scene
you know that's and that was the opening
of the movie yeah let's go so then it
was like i'm the first thing you hear
and see in the movie
and then we have this little they added
this dinner scene the minds would just
keep me and you know and so then
that would that that you know that was
that you know so it's great
funny story though i say to uh um
you know standard i go yeah my special
just came out man you know he was like
i'm gonna watch it he's in his phone
like what's the name of the thing you
know so then later now we're
that was in montreal so now we're in uh
la
you know doing like it's downtown new
york was this your special on show time
yeah yeah and so now he's telling a
story about how he knows the the dude
from game of thrones the the little dude
oh yeah peter dick yeah and
he's saying how yeah you know i i
actually have never watched game of
thrones but you know i was making out
like then i said
you never watched my special
because he said he watched it right yeah
i was like oh man did you do that to me
yeah you didn't watch my special then he
does that adam sanders and he was like i
want yeah
but he's a fun dude and then like
recently i went to like a
i just had a meeting i was trying to
pitch something with them you know
whatever
and then like the was it the happy
sandler or yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you have to be
happy madison yeah you know and then his
main guy was like uh
oh yeah you know they're writing murder
mystery too right now you know or
whatever they're writing you know
whatever
whatever kind of sequel they're going to
do and i'm like jimmy better be in it
yeah you know what i mean
yeah we need jimmy and then he like took
a picture of me and sent it to the
writer like don't forget this guy
there it is have you been touring at all
no
no i actually just went to for the first
time i went to arizona
last weekend shouts out to phoenix i
want to stand up
live that was your first it was my first
weekend and it was like
i was like nervous but i was more
nervous about my set
than i was about getting coveted for
sure because at this point i'm like
i've taken four tests i feel like i'm
doing the right things
i mean who knows i can still get it for
whatever reason right but at this point
right now i'm not living in fear the way
they want you to yeah you know what i
mean
so i just went you know i got on a plane
that was i was nervous about that i hate
wearing the mask so now i'm in this mask
i said i mean how can i deal with this i
saw it i'm glad it was phoenix it's just
an
hour flight yeah this is a tester flight
let me just see how this is
you know got to the hotel everything was
cool i went inside a restaurant and i
was like oh
[ __ ] you feel weird right you know what
i mean get in there i was like insane
and then
then it just made me mad i'm like what
are we doing here what are we doing in
l.a yeah what are we doing why are we
doing it like yeah yeah bro
we went to florida and then texas has a
no mass mandate
oh texas the governor just said
yesterday like yeah we're 100 open
and then newsom here i looked around the
news he's like i'd
prefer if you guys wore two masks i'm
like god damn oh
it is weird damn it's like how are we
are we living in the same place i just
don't get it like
like cause they're all getting the same
info and here's the thing too right but
here's
two we're not gonna know and if the
governor of texas
he's either gonna be proven right or
proven wrong okay
so if he's proven right the numbers keep
dropping
everything's fine in texas you know
people still get it but
lb i guarantee that you know it's gonna
if it still drops
then we're really gonna be mad here
listen man it's 20 21 we all have
stresses in life
especially right now but one thing you
shouldn't be stressing out about
is breakouts we're talking about acne
you should not
be stressing about acne in 2021 because
there's proactive man we got you covered
stubborn breakouts no problemo sensitive
skin type with occasional pimples no
problemo
proactiv has you covered proactive
combines gentle skin care
paired with clinically proven acne
fighting ingredients to treat your skin
find the right proactive system for you
they have three
different type of systems designed for
your skin
number one we got proactive solution the
original system which your boy used here
in high school
definitely helped check out the skin now
popping glowing uh
proactive plus for sensitive skin types
than proactive md
prescription strength for the stubborn
breakouts it's the first combination
therapy system that started a skin care
revolution
all right so it's easy it's easy to do
you feel great get rid of
acne if you're super self-conscious
about it this is definitely a step
in the right direction man we got you
covered all right
so you guys it's a great great time to
try proactive for the 500 kids listeners
you get a special limited time offer by
going to proactive.com
fighter that's p r o a c t i v dot com
slash fighter
subscribe today and you will receive
proactives hydration
duo as a free gift that includes four
hydrogel masks and the green tea
moisturizer
best of all you get free shipping again
visit proactive.com
fighter to take advantage of this
special offer now that's proactive.com
fighter and subscribe to constantly
clear skin you know
this day and age man there's a lot of
headphones out there you're flying on
planes
maybe your thick ass is on a bike like
me maybe you're just listening to music
at home whatever you're doing
you know maybe your phone came with some
headphones that you like
i'm telling you man this isn't even in
the script i'm freaking telling you the
raycon wireless earbuds
are the best earbuds i've ever had i'm
obsessed with them
i ca i ride my bike i listen to podcasts
on their noise canceling for me
they fit my weird ears it's great man
get a pair of raycons in your ears and
it can make all the freaking
different it's a game changer there's no
dangling wire or stems to get
in your way raycons come in a range of
stylish colorways
but always with a comfortable in-air fit
for a more discreet look
all right the raycons are built to
perform anytime
anywhere with water and sweat resistant
construction and bluetooth appears
quickly
seamlessly it's super easy has a battery
life for six
hours that's why i love it um the best
part raycon makes great sound accessible
to everyone with wireless earbuds
starting at half the price
of other premium auto brands i'm telling
you guys they're my
favorite favorite favorite raycon's
offering 15
off their products for you guys and
here's what you got to do to get it go
to
buy raycon r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash
t-f-a-t-k that's it you get 15 off your
entire raycon order
so feel free to grab up here and that's
15
off at byraycon.com
t f a t k by raycon dot com slash t
f a t k is it about health
or is there something else at play yeah
and then something that you know when
trump was in office they're like oh
he's throwing fake news we need a real
president in there and then buying gets
him is like or
is the news clear for you yeah like are
things clear now yeah
i think that no the politicians get
i think conservative radio and
television
they love if they're in a better
position
when biden is the president than trump
because now
they're on the attack 24 7. as opposed
to like defending
yeah as opposed to having to like gloss
over some [ __ ] yeah you know like out of
capital ryan wasn't that bad
you see him go down
now you guys see him go down this double
diamond mogul trying to figure out like
how are we gonna defend that this riot
wasn't that bad
now they're just like blind sucks yeah i
can't believe it works president in
history now they just like ooh they're
in there like sean
kennedy isn't it
i don't have to [ __ ] defend this
idiot because he knows like you he can't
he can't believe the things that he was
saying well but now cnn
now cnn's on the defensive the best to
see them struggle through the cuomo now
they know how it is there's three
sexual assault charges yeah cuomo yeah
in new york
so he's like trying to like battle that
it's such a beast
he's like i'm old that's my grandpa used
to greet me like that
you're like all right man all right my
grandma used to greet that's what he
said
he's like my grandfather used to grab my
face like that
you know it's funny you say that the
whole in the whole room everyone's like
yeah yeah some things you shouldn't know
what though in his defense
there there is some truth to that your
grandma used to grab you there is some
truth to how we used to be he's a talent
in the same way that we used to be more
you know casually racist we used to be
more what i'm saying is like drop the f
word
yeah we used to like gays you know like
it was very casual yeah man it's a
different time
different era you know like even my oh
man my we
my mom like you look at your parents
your parents have
very racist ideas my grandmother is so
you know my mom would say some [ __ ] like
okay well my mom was with when the
dementia wasn't you know
one of my closest closest friends is gay
all right okay he's a brother to me you
know
and uh he was he was sick and i said to
my mom i said yeah yeah he's not feeling
well
my mom goes hope it's not aids
listen i won't be on camera just let us
know that's that error that's that error
so you know it's like you know it's like
it's so i'm not
i'm not saying it's okay but the thing
is science is bliss to the like back
then like they didn't know
it's like it was it
girl hanging out with all these black
guys
yeah i don't want you hanging out with
these guys with giant hits all the time
okay oh man it's a real weird thing but
so now again
you know the sensitivity or the things
are being weaponized to get you know
you know you know just we just have to
try to weather the storm i wish it
wasn't so
you got to tiptoe was it wasn't so
politicized and stuff like that but you
know
social media heightens everything too
again not defending cuomo in any way
but but but i i understand you know what
i mean like i'm what i'm saying is like
you go okay well what's happening here
so he did what to you you know like like
what i don't like is the association
that is all catch-all so
you know some guy from an old era you
know that sees you and he just goes ah i
gotta yell you pinches your cheek or
whatever
whatever the thing or however the hello
is if you're trying to say that's the
same as he put
um drugs in your drink and then you woke
up naked
next to them yeah different are you is
there no is there no distinction
between what you know like so sexual
assault is now the catch-all for
everything
yeah catch on for everything and you're
gonna take a blanket
different man it's like and it's like if
you believe that then i go okay
you know because like there's look
listen get messing with people's
boundaries and in their state their
space
you know you you don't know but what i'm
saying is
give somebody the opportunity what we
what we need to do move
moving forward is like we have to make
it okay for people to say like
like you got to go hey can i hug you i'm
a hugger you know
that's what i do now yeah yeah you know
i'm a hugger you know okay
you know because maybe somebody's not a
hugger you might hug somebody squeeze
your entire
they might feel uncomfortable i didn't
like what he did yeah yeah you know and
then they go to hr
you know [ __ ] but what i'm saying is do
we have to assume
everyone's a creep can it be like you
know i didn't really feel comfortable
with that
can i get the opportunity to go like oh
man my bad well i was listening to
breakfast club and
they were talking about like the works
because they were saying you know cuomo
in the workspace and they worked for him
and
they're not allowed to do that so
they're having a discussion on all three
of them
envy uh charlemagne and julie they're
like
there should be no flirting in the
workspace
and in my head i'm like that that's not
right you're assuming all those guys are
creeps and you're assuming
all the girls don't want to be hit on
well also most a lot of relationships
start in the workplace
i was just about to say yeah geraldo
said that he was like you know talking
about news people that have gotten
together people that work together
like at what point you know so you i get
it so
because of this you have to have a
catch-all so so because of a few creeps
you have to go okay so none of this
should happen at work and i totally get
that though
like there is a part of it that you go
like you're on a movie set
you know and maybe you and the makeup
lady are vibing
okay i'm with you all right but during
the shooting
it's probably best that you keep it
professional
for sure okay on that rap day oh
that's when you like listen you free on
saturday yeah okay okay i've been
you know so what i'm saying is it's more
nuanced than just being like
hey none of this ever you know that's
also not realistic
it's not realistic but because what but
the problem is it's like
unfortunately the few creeps that take
[ __ ] too far ruined it
uh ruined it and even even ourselves we
can look at ourselves
every man i'm i don't care you could
pretend like you're not whatever you
want everybody can lie to themselves
every dude if you look at it on paper
has crossed the line okay interesting
like hey because it depends on
the circumstances and the situation and
the person you're talking to
one line that might work on one chick
it's completely inappropriate to another
one yeah
it also depends on like unfortunately
the difference between um
annoyance and harassment and
acceptance it's a final is attraction
yeah
yeah you know so it just
you know you know you know so but so you
as a guy i just think that we need to
find
we need to try to act more appropriately
more professional more professional in
professional settings i don't think
there's anything wrong with that
you know it's like it's because then you
know you know because that's because
everybody's drunks to extremes
so when we're trying to say like i think
it should be okay to date somebody that
you work with
the the extreme people will be like yo
so you think you could grab her ass at
work and
and say no yeah i'm not saying that no
[ __ ]
yeah they stop putting words in my mouth
yeah because they don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
when i say [ __ ] i mean [ __ ]
yeah when you say [ __ ] you say i like
it i
just want my favorite words [ __ ] you
know and i don't mean it the way people
you didn't stop calling people [ __ ] i
don't you know but it's like you just
say [ __ ] yeah that's
just that's at different levels you know
so i just think that
when you so how did you do that so it is
case by case
look when i i probably even said this on
this podcast already but
i remember we had this um for a dine up
here
you know because then it was like me too
error was heavy all right so they had
they would always have a lawyer come in
a consultant before the you start
shooting
and they sit everybody down and they
talk about sexual harassment on the job
but one of the things the lady said it
was like listen
this is not something that you can
necessarily like put on paper
but you know it when you see it right
okay it's just like pornography you know
it's like if you have some art book
with like you know it's like statues of
babies and there's like baby booties and
stuff like that
someone easy could be like oh my god
what is this child pornography but you
look at it and you would be like no no
this is art it's clearly art
but like who defines that yeah so like
you like you know when you see it and
harassment is the same kind of thing
all i said to her was hello yeah but did
you go
hello
okay
so i mean there is a way of like you
know you know
you know it's like no okay it's like i
remember i was just i was at this
restaurant
uh uh um what is that place uh crap
jones on third
third hell yeah okay do you know jones
all right so you know when jones you
sitting at tables like this
uh-huh very right and then there's like
people could be right here so
behind me two girls sitting here right
me and my buddy we're just talking
a dude comes over and starts flirting
with these girls
okay yeah he don't know him and it just
it just doesn't go well okay
all right but my thing is like i'm
sitting like this and the girl's sitting
like this so we're literally like this
close to each other okay when the guy
leaves let me
go that didn't go well huh and she was
like oh my god that sure did it
and we started yapping all right she
she's one of these hippie chicks she's
hippie she's got a tank top on dirty air
force
you know what i mean of the conference
in the middle of the conversation
her titty pops up
dude i would say [ __ ]
i was just watching what did you do
i don't tell her the titties out but
then she looks down and sees the titties
out
and knows i've been looking at this
titty the whole time
was it a big-ass city it was normal
but it was like
you but i made the choice
i need to tell her about this titty yeah
she need to know about just titties but
how
i tell her about the titty is where
the harassment comes guys make a joke
because i can't be like this
your titty out
yeah and later i could say what
i was telling her her her breast was out
and i needed you know
no so i just went um excuse excuse me
but um you did you did a little more
yeah
all right but anyway the point is the
point is i felt like batman
i would i knew in that situation i said
i'm not even listening to her because
she's a mom
because i'm thinking titty and i need to
i need to let her know
yeah you know what i mean i'm just like
looking at her like this
while i get this titty into the
conversation without being a creep
yeah and you know and so what i'm saying
is like it's one of these things that i
say
you know it when you see it you you can
feel it you know when a dude is like
it's like after shows man and you got
these chicks and and and with their
boyfriends and you know and the chick's
a little drunk and she's like
i like him you know yeah and then you
know you gotta look at the boyfriend
like yeah
oh my gosh yeah awkward [ __ ] yeah you
know cause i might [ __ ] her tonight
i'm just kidding just kidding rachel
that's my fiancee
i was like what the [ __ ] the music
expressed by eric in this joke
clearly that's the fiance camera right i
know i know baby
so but what i'm saying is like you
sometimes you have you had these moments
okay so you know you just gotta go like
hey
how do you deal with it and then you
know what you know you have other
situations where the couple looks like
the guy's like
yeah she like you brendan she always
meaning like he wants you to [ __ ] his
girl and then you want to sit in the
chair and come back
back up okay so what i'm saying is like
you know how you handle that you're just
like uh
i mean you know you know what i mean
like how far is the chair from the bed
you know
i mean again you know interactions
between human beings
are way more complex and nuanced
which is my favorite i use it all the
time it's way more
it's way more than just a headline on
twitter you know
it's way more than that because people
still take your words they'll parse them
and make them
always no matter what what they want but
i say to you okay so
so even if you're doing it like that
then you can
see how there's all different types of
perceptions
you know what i've been saying on my
podcast look i don't mind that people
are sensitive
all right i'm sensitive i'm a sensitive
guy me too that's why when
something happens and somebody says
something about me i get sensitive
so i'm no longer being like oh this
generation is sensitive no they
i don't mind you being sensitive but
what i mind is is when you weaponize it
when you take your sensitivity to the
internet
based off your perception and you
weaponize
against someone yeah without giving me
an example
what an example would be like you know
taylor swift okay so she's now upset
that a show made a joke about her oh
yeah
netflix show yeah this nephew she made
it so she turned her so she tweeted out
yeah
she tweeted out like this is lazy
writing and you know she made it like
she made herself the victim in this
situation
and it's like it's like damn so she took
her 100 million followers
and she has an army of people she has a
[ __ ]
if anybody could take a joke it should
be
the people in the public eye like that
yeah yeah like
it's it should be easy that should be
lightworked
and the joke was like the two characters
were talking to the ladies said that and
she says um oh you go through more men
than twilight taylor swift
shannon lyon the thing is
it's not even about that the point is
it's like so then to like weaponize
her sensitivity yes on her twitter i
think is irresponsible
yeah i think it's irresponsible i feel
like it's unfair or even like it's like
it's just happened to me in phoenix i
have joke i'm working at these jokes man
i have been on stage in a year i'm
working out i'm not making excuses
because
even if you say something that somebody
gets hurt it's like okay but i feel like
in my mind i'm making a good point and i
and i feel like i'm coming from a good
place i don't have ill intent
you know and like one of us do when we
go up there but like i said
there's gonna be a butt of every joke
and sometimes that butt gets slapped
and people don't like that some people
do some people don't
and i get it so you made somebody upset
she tweets about it you know
what was the topic just about
transgender it doesn't even matter you
know they just i was really upset and
hurt and it was hurtful and bold but i
got
my initial reaction i was like [ __ ] you
yeah you know what i mean like you
didn't hear what i said you know what i
mean yeah but that's that person's
perception but again
no details now people that weren't even
there what an [ __ ]
i can't believe this yeah meanwhile
what i'm saying is you're valid to have
your feelings
i'm okay with you being upset and i can
even be like you know what just two
times you should apologize to people
all right when you do wrong and if
someone's hurt by something that you did
whether you meant to do wrong or not so
i can sit here now and be like
she was hurt by what i said and i and i
can be like i apologize that you were
hurt by that
okay i'm sorry that you were hurt by
that i'm working this out
and now i see a different perspective
actually because afterwards i was like
mad and i'm looking at the jokes and i'm
thinking about him
and then i'm like well maybe somebody
could see it this way so i need to be
more clear in how i do this joke
that's all it is so i'm working it out
but damn for you to make it now that
you characterizing me as a monster
because of your sensitivity and your
perception
anti-transgender that's what chemistry
is
correct yeah to make someone a monster
yeah so cancer culture becomes this
thing where like
without details without first-hand
knowledge without
you're going to take that sensitivity
and you're going to weaponize it
and i just find that that is i i think
it doesn't move us forward
it doesn't move us forward i mean
conversations are what moves us forward
i mean
and it's like all i say to people that
come to comedy shows or you're talking
about comedians
let's assume good intentions first
before anything yes they're [ __ ] yes
there are people clearly trying to be
mean
but let's assume
i don't have ill intent i'm just working
this out especially in my mind
because i'm saying like the whole point
of it is to be like we shouldn't
normalize this it shouldn't matter
we shouldn't care about this as much as
we do now within that i'm gonna have
jokes
because i go after both sides i don't
care like
my favorite compliment is when a
republican conservative person comes up
to me after my show and goes yeah thanks
for talking about both sides
you know and they're not saying to me
why'd you do jokes about conservatives
they're going
thanks for joking about them too yeah
you say everybody get
everybody everybody get in nobody and my
thing is like don't you want to feel
normal
don't you want to be like you're at a
show and no matter who you are
you're going gonna get it yeah you're
good you're you're you're you're a part
of what i feel like because i don't
i don't look like i hate when people
assume my intent yeah yeah yeah don't
assume that don't
don't assume my intuition don't assume
i'm telling you what my intent is now if
i didn't achieve that
if i because you know what the real
issue is we're not as brilliant as we
think we are
people aren't as articulate as they
think they are even right now
people are misconstruing what we're
saying or they're taking what they want
from it
it's actually harder than you think to
articulate your point yeah and that's
why when you're a comic
you have to work on your act many many
times while we go up so much
and it's like in this situation that
wasn't a special
that is for public consumption i've been
on stage in a year
can we just have this moment in this
crowd just right here
can we have this moment maybe hit me up
privately like i didn't like what you
said
yeah then i could be like well [ __ ] you
and then we go back and forth and i go
you know what you're right yeah yeah
it's because
my mistake was i tweeted back and then
other people yeah then other people
jumped in this guy's like
what an [ __ ] for responding like this
and i said you weren't even there you
weren't even there
and then he goes well you just keep
talking everything you write you know
what i said back to him i was like
you know what you're right they said you
killed them off like i said i said
you're right
because i'm just upset man you know i
don't i'm upset by this unfair
characterization that's what i wrote
back
didn't hear from that [ __ ] again
yeah put him on mute you know he was i
mean
everybody anyway cause i was like i made
a mistake of even saying anything
because you know
if like you tell me man man i went to
this place
and everybody's getting on me whatever
and then like we can what they getting
on you now all i can believe is you
i i i could be but then i come to find
out you know you were being a dick well
now you have detail
i have you cancel culture
is lack of details you know and even
these details that they think they get
they think well i got details they said
in the story
where's the proof yeah you know can we
see it all first
and then go all right now i'll make a
comment on all of it let's make a
comment on this now
but we don't wait for that and then it
runs a muck castle coaster
is out of hand and there's no putting
the two toothpaste back in the bottle
right once it's out then it's just like
and like i'll say again i have no
problem anymore
i don't mind that this generation is
sensitive we're all what i realize is
we're all sensitive sensitive most
entertainers are
athletes and you know what else i
realized too
it's cancelled culture or sensitivity
it's always been here
they just now have an outlet they have a
platform they have a platform
yeah before they had to write letters
yeah you know man
eddie murphy would talk about it any
time he did a show he would he'd read
about it in the newspaper or something
really that's how it would be so now
people have their own voice so i guess i
realized like george carlin would have
got it
he would have been god okay just because
he was
he had these opinions you know what i
mean there would be people that are
building right
you are so insensitive you know what i
mean so you just go so i get it so i
just feel like it's like it's unfair you
know what i mean
and at the same time fear another side
look taylor swift is upset
you know i get it she's like damn my
business always got to be the butt of
every [ __ ] joke
you know what i mean do i have you know
so she was mad about that all right
i i'm with you nobody wants to be the
butt of a joke
see the butt of the joke got slapped
that's her ass okay she got slapped
but she clapped back in a way that's
like damn
you don't take you like that's a weapon
major way
it's a major weapon it's like that she's
abusing her it's like that time bieber
you know put somebody's phone number
like uh or email or something like look
it's like if bieber goes uh there's
people this look what this person said
about me
189 million people now or whatever
they're going to see
whatever they're doing i'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
how dare you leave him alone that's a
danger that's like
that's a dangerous weapon you know but
we don't even realize it until you're
like
because even i would do that you know
when somebody says some [ __ ] about you
and you go
ha look at this troll boom and then your
fans are like troll
stupid trolls they light them up you
know what i mean
and that's like you know it's like you
don't even realize the the
the power that that wields and someone
like taylor swift
she's got a national platform she's got
so many followers she's got diamonds
she's worldwide so she tweets something
the world looks
she knows what's going to happen yeah
that's what i'm saying she's not like
what she's doing she's a smart girl
she might have been at home like i'm
[ __ ] them i'm a watch
well she's like i'm sick of this yeah
watch this and again by the way
more power to you but like you know
don't be like lazy writing you know
you have songs that are like i will
never ever ever shakespeare
you know what i mean yeah so but again
but again
i get it you know and i'm saying it's
like we just don't realize the extent of
how far we could go
with yeah with with this ingredient it's
like you you get the fact that the
person has that emotion like that
cause i do this on my podcast sometimes
yeah this guy was talking about like
his kid and this is the third time i'm
talking about this how mad i am about it
you know what i mean so i'm actually
doing what i said you know people should
do
doing it right you got to unleash it
back [ __ ] i don't understand but
i hear about it
example of the kind of thing so the guy
like he you know he first and he
writes a comment and calls my girl
stupid oh wow you know and so i said you
know
i was like yo dude do you think this is
okay like this is not okay you know you
know this is some
somebody i care about on instagram
you're like you think it's cool on
youtube also you think this is okay dude
oh you're responding
to youtube comments yeah oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
brother
but then the guy writes me back like
well you know mike we i was watching you
game
i'm a fan and my son sent you a super
chat which is like tip
you know and then he asked to play with
you and then you said
why would i play with you you know now
out of context it's like
you know i'm like yeah when i'm playing
i'm like you know how many people hit me
up to play
likewise like i'm i'm talking about it's
just non-stop messages like here's my
here's my activision id
i want to play call of duty with you but
i can't play with everybody i don't know
you
yeah that's what i'm saying why would i
play with you i don't know you they
don't know you i don't know this is a
little kid
[Laughter]
i don't know what was this tag i don't
even know don't matter i'm not talking
about that i'm just saying
i don't know it's a little kid but if
you watch me all the time you get my
sentiment
my sentiment is like come on y'all i
can't play with all y'all now if the kid
was upset if
it came across rude to this individual i
get it i'm sorry all right
i didn't mean for you to be hurt by my
dismissal but also
two dollars you think two dollars means
you own my time now
you think you're buying me for yeah you
got two dollars like oh damn
yeah yeah it's like yeah [ __ ] yeah he
does think that we sent you two dollars
so
what i'm saying is like so this guy
again people take their perception
their perspective and then they attack
you were you guys cool though
and i haven't heard from him since
because i know he's seen me talk about
this now and he must be
he must let him know he's like yeah i
think your bad parenting is really
what's going on right now
letting your kids feel like oh yeah you
can buy whatever you want
you want to buy eric you're gonna buy it
send that [ __ ]
so what i'm saying is like you know
again i get sensitive taylor swift was
sensitive
she was mad she was probably looking at
your show she was trying to let me watch
this new show
oh girl power it's girls you know
national women's month you know and
she's like going for it and then she
sees this joke
you know she's in her palatial palace
and they're like california king
you know what i mean there's two asian
boys fanning her yeah you know what i'm
saying
they're just asian boys you know what i
mean
there's like you know somebody's doing
her nails whatever and she's just
sitting there with all her money and
everything and she's like
[ __ ] them yep unleash the fury [ __ ] them
you know what hit the nuke
and she's a celebrity you know what i
mean she has the most
engagement interaction with her fans
yeah and she's super she's great
so she's great that way you know like
you you have and that's what's great
about see this is how the
the internet we can that's why i hope
they never get rid of it it's because
the positive
is of it you could be a fan of taylor
swift yeah and there could be a chance
that she goes
hey what's up yeah yeah yeah and you're
live yeah
whatever it is listen i remember meeting
bieber you know
at uh the laugh factory and he took a
picture of us
you know he took a picture and he put it
on his instagram you know and i said
well can i
could you tag me man he was like all
right and i said let me do for you and
then i was doing this phone
but he was so cautious with his phone i
remember he would he was gonna grab it
because he was like get it because i was
going let me see these dick pics
i know what he thought i was gonna look
at but then like he um
you know and then he tagged me and then
my phone blew up for six months
yeah like i had to turn the
notifications off because it was like
damn oh [ __ ] yeah
you know and then i was getting messages
too i was getting messages from like
young girls like can you can you tell
justin yeah can you just tell justin
that happened
by the way young boys too boys are going
to be like oh yes i i
need him you know what
it was like last night me and my girl
watching that billy eilish doc have you
seen that is that good have you seen it
yeah i watched it it's [ __ ] good it's
good you're a huge fan of her after you
see
her mom and like brother did a bunch of
like just normal camera [ __ ] like it's
not like
hd like it's like the dad with a camera
when they're kids
it's dope man but you you she doesn't
talk about it's not on her instagram but
during all this like when she's just
starting to like blow the [ __ ] up
when all those you know grammys and all
that she has this dude
his name's q this black dude who
kind of like like she gets she does
coachella and before as she's driving
coachella
she you're you're like so frustrated at
her because
this guy's kind of a tool he looks like
a dumbass and she's just and she's 17.
she's
her first love how is he she was 16. 16.
he's probably 17.
no he's 22 at the time is he 22. he was
22 at the time oh that's time
yeah a lot of people came out after that
documentary because they looked him up
and then they're like wait why so i told
you
you told me you hear the tone of her
voice yeah she got a paralegal tone in
her voice
objection your honor
i didn't know that but what's
interesting what's interesting
is as i'm watching the doctor look at my
girlfriend i bet that dude q
is getting annihilated on social media
yes
because he's a dick like she's going to
coachella
she's headline coachella you know it's a
big [ __ ] deal
she's 16. and she's on the bus at
coachella and
you know they're passing billboards over
her album's about to drop
and you know she should be excited about
that she's calling having
drama with this dumb ass and she's like
are you going baby i love you and he's
like
you know what's he acting all cool he's
i gotta see and he's like you know i'll
do that for you so
he gets there and she's like where's the
[ __ ] i haven't he said he's gonna hang
out with me i've seen him in two days he
took my vip passes
i haven't seen him in two days and then
finally
finally yeah probably sold them but then
finally they're in the green room
and you know she does her thing and
crushes on stage and gets back and she's
like
where where are you at and she's like no
i can't come to you like i'm
i can't leave the there's fans out there
she's like can you just please come here
and he's like nah you need to come to me
she's like i i can't i'm billy eilish
like i can't come
and i'm just i'm watching i'm like this
dude i bet is about
his life's about to change and not for
the betterment apparently he didn't have
much of a
social media presence before he was kind
of there but not really used it much
and after the documentary came out she
actually had to make a statement saying
like please leave him alone
like he didn't ask for i knew you knew
this was gonna happen like because she
her friend
and she's sick she's just excuse me
she's as precious 16
objection um they didn't film it in one
day and then put it out
okay no no there was editing there was
years viewing process
it's it's over they knew exactly what
was happening no bill billy knows that
she absolutely knew i but it's not like
you don't really
know his actual name they go by like his
nickname and people found him that's a
dog
because he was like a soundcloud oh
they'll find him no matter what
dive into the details okay soundcloud
let's dive into the start there yeah
let's start here okay go ahead okay
one she was probably like i could see
her being like
you always want to get back at your
haters or people that doubted you when
you were coming up
okay here's this guy you didn't think i
was gonna make it
you know and she wanted you he's a black
dude so she want to use the n-word but
she can't
well i'm sure they edited that out
over there
this is a clap back yeah moment but good
for her to realize
oops i i when we're in the middle i
looked at my girl at this point that cue
i don't know how old he is his life is
not going
to check it out though check it out i'm
just going to make my
mama do my assumptions okay this is you
know it's like
he's a soundcloud rapper that's it he
ain't making it
whoa his hair's no he ain't making it
he's not making it no no check this out
you i'm talking about at that time okay
you're a soundcloud rapper yeah here's
your girl who
you like her songs they cute yeah billy
you're like baby you're going you know
oh yeah let me
do that song for me again baby yeah next
thing you know she's at coachella
headlining and your dumb ass is still
soundcloud rapping
yeah you know what i mean of course he
was that's why he was acting like that
coming to you because he was too
arrogant yeah he was too
his ego got crushed right and then
and the sad part is that's that's this
is why women
are so precious this is why women are so
precious and so loving this is why
they have more of that in them than any
man does
she's headlining coachella that's big
and she's still
baby are you coming oh dude gets off
[ __ ] him
oh dude i was fired up i'm like get rid
of this loser
you're billy eilish because dude you
know how many dudes unfortunately good
dude
you probably didn't talk when it don't
work it's like we need to be more like
that dudes because we are so career
driven
yeah we're so career driven yeah we
gonna be like i'm bringing you with me
we'll be doing this
but hey i gotta go do this okay i've
just learned in this past year to repr
reprioritize yeah now i might be like no
i'm not going to do that 10 p.m
set at the comedy store tonight yeah i'm
gonna hang with my lady damn me too
that's what i've learned from this
me too but anyway my point to get back
to it is like like
how precious is it that she cared more
about
not being at coachella but wanting her
man to see her echo
but it's not even cute he's a piece of
[ __ ] soundcloud rapper but the thing is
it's
you can see like you know she has all
this love she
i'm talking her her brother goes look
this is your spotify number she's like
she's just so innocent and you're like
oh my god we need to protect her because
she's like oh that's
that's a hundred and fourteen thousand
or whatever and her brother's like
no no billy that's that's 114 million in
a day
downloads she's like on my song and
you're like oh my god
so i know dude this is nice to protect
this [ __ ] i love her i know so she's so
talented and then
this what's dope she does coachella
crushes it meets
her so her idol she posts a video when
she was 10 talking about justin bieber
she had so much
such an obsession with justin bieber her
mom was like i think we need to get her
help
because she was crying in the video
because she's like i can't love another
man
more than i love justin bieber so justin
bieber surprises her
comes up behind her at coachella and
goes like this and she turns around and
starts shaking
yeah and then they become friends yeah
and then uh her manager it's dope she's
at home
liv still lives with her parents and
this busted [ __ ] dirty as [ __ ] the whole
documentary yeah even when she has
millions of dollars
just bus as [ __ ] this crib she makes all
her music in her brother's room still
so it's dope and they go through them
writing songs together
and like all her big hits it's on there
she's like well what if we
when she goes with that song bad guy
she's like well what if we did like
like like i'm a bad guy and the
brother's like oh that's dope and then
you know how big of a hit is he yeah
yeah but it just shows her being like oh
what if we did this you're like
she's so [ __ ] talented man it's nuts
so but then she's back at her house and
her manager
calls her and he's like hey uh i don't
know if you saw but you got a dm from
justin bieber and she's like
what she freaks [ __ ] out and uh she uh
the manager's like yeah he wants to do a
collab with you
do you want to do it and she's like
going [ __ ] nuts man
of course nuts and even with all that
look at that
bieber hat oh you have no i know yeah
bieber's nuts man before he was married
but what else is insane she you know
she's her brother goes
something like oh we doing made a joke
you know i love her brother he goes
oh we're doing billionaire [ __ ] and then
uh
billy's like no we're not billionaires
she goes we definitely have millions of
dollars though
they start laughing like villains in a
[ __ ] movie like
my baby just escaped the bank yeah but i
mean like that being said she wanted a
car
for her birthday and she's like oh all i
want is a
dodge challenger i'm like oh we need to
get her a red-eye hellcat okay that'd be
dope
dude they bring up her car and you know
how much she has like she won
five grand with six grammys in one night
they bring up this car
it's the base model three i'm like
look at that she's still 17. yeah that's
that's what my girl said yeah she's
still like
because the hellcat has like damn near a
thousand horsepower yeah my girl goes
who the [ __ ] would get a 17 year old
hellcam like
i would six grammys you bring up this
bass [ __ ]
you're a mountain you're a monster yeah
you're right you know what he is he's
like the guy that he'll have his
daughter on like you know
my sweet 16 on mtv you know oh i
remember
how monsters are created right you got
davis yeah
let's break so this is your current
event yeah why do you have lifting
gloves on
oh [ __ ] i didn't even see that i don't
want to see the video what what
nothing's accomplished
my girl my girl my girl's like your
hands are too hard yeah
yeah yeah don't wear that she bought
okay so no more gloves never again
okay all right well this is my gym man
at ectomorph's
you know basil we got like you wear
whatever you want in your hands protect
yourself
go ahead continue yeah look you noticed
10 45 plus i
you noticed that so his covert is just
coming right on your face
this isn't a gym that's an alley and you
have the lifting gloves on well
why do you have a belt
again i gotta let's focus on let's focus
on you're not even going down to your
chest no my trainer said my trainer said
just keep it oh yeah
your trainer looks in shape he look he's
big he ain't [ __ ]
you can we can't listen to him when he's
skinny look at that i'm going all the
way down it's parallel to my chest
that's eight right there
hey i'll give him that's
we would not count those reps that's 10.
that's not 10.
that actually it actually seems harder
to do it that way without the
it's easier you're only going down here
no no you look how excited he is
yeah i want to protect myself so you
mean tell me check yourself at all costs
come on
that's what they tell you before you
fight like so you lift like an extra
from pumping iron
in the 80s what do you have all that
[ __ ] on i look like the nba player that
had an armband and nobody picked them up
yeah man
you got a skinny trainer just skinny on
skinny it's an alley that wasn't your
finest moment yeah
i'm talking about [ __ ] you
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
wait what is this okay so a few weeks
ago we talked about how
china was implementing a new cova test
which is an anal swap
yep and they were forcing a lot of
people to do these anal swaps because
they're saying that
you can actually pick up more traces of
covid through fecal matter than you can
through the nostrils or your uh mouth
but what ended up happening is that if
you're a let's
keep coming back
i'm not feeling so great
so shortly after they announced that
everyone was going to have to do an anal
swab at some point in china
um a lot of people from the embassy here
who are working from the united states
says that they didn't have to take the
anal swabs thankfully
however they did china wow they did come
out and say that apparently
japanese embassy workers were uh
forced to do them and so japan came out
and asked china like hey can we
not force our japanese citizens to have
anal swab tests
because the u.s doesn't have to do it
like do you think we get sick with the
nose man
does that work like that works dude
let's do
that
psychologically damaging to japanese
citizens to be foreign
yeah that's anybody dude you do that in
america
ain't nobody getting tested no i'd
rather get covered you can get a few
freaks for a downpour but other than
that
all right okay so we also
talked about the girl who put gorilla
glue in her hair
what happened was there is a i forgot
he was a plastic surgeon here in beverly
hills he found her video and said that
he wanted to help her for free
he helped her remove the gorilla glue
from her hair and while they were
talking
he got to know her better and said you
know what i'll help you with whatever
other cosmetic procedures you want to do
she was gonna
get i believe a tummy tuck and then a
breast augmentation
when they were doing her uh pre-op
consultation they found lumps in her
breast
and so she's saying that it's kind of
she feels like it was meant to be that
she put gorilla glue in her hair because
that's the only way she would have found
out about the lumps in her breast
whatever makes you feel dude good for
doing that stupid [ __ ] it's kind of
sound like a weird sound like a weird
hmo though
yeah she's trying to lay it flat and
then what happened just got stuck
oh yeah that was a problem now with the
lumps like that that doesn't mean breast
cancer is just
it does oh yeah you don't have random
lumps in your teeth
yeah you're not supposed to have lumps
in your breasts yeah damn
so right now she's going to undergo uh
cancer treatment mother of five now i'm
sure the gorilla group people got to put
out like
videos like please do not do this you
know
the guy that was like i believe that
[ __ ] oh
one of those like red drinking cups puts
on your seat
and then just picture him in the
hospital because he's just [ __ ]
sitting there
cut his lip off they
what else you got that was the picture
was so funny i know it's focusing
him in the er like laying like this in
the comments
oh [ __ ] so this video is insane um
there is a clip that a woman posted onto
i think it's true
uh posted onto her facebook it's a
vietnamese woman looking outside the
window
of her apartment complex and she is i
think 13 to 14 stories
up she looks down at the 12th floor and
sees a child hanging from the balcony
and it doesn't seem like anyone's home
and so it doesn't seem like anyone can
help everyone's screaming
and this video shows the baby fall 12 uh
stories
however what the video doesn't show you
is there's a man at the bottom who heard
the screaming he was a delivery service
man
wow he was scaling the walls climbed on
top of a roof of a building right next
to it
he actually caught the baby are you the
baby that's
that's impressive but this is the video
and it's very i don't want to watch it
y'all see the dude
that's our inside voice for that baby to
hang on there that long
was something underneath his feet
oh [ __ ]
and that banging sound was actually the
sound of the man uh catching the baby
so he dented the metal roof he was not
harmed the baby uh
i believe she dislocated a part of her
hip but other than that she's gonna be
perfectly fine insane
and with child services as well right
i have no idea that's the scary thing
like this everyone was screaming it
seems
like for a while you would have woken up
if you heard that yeah and checked on
everybody the whole neighborhood and the
man says that he's really
happy that he was able to save the baby
and he's most excited about the fact
that his facebook posts
are now gaining traction of thousands of
followers rather than a few
people that's all he cares about yeah he
also says that people
have been sending him money through like
a phone number maybe like cash out and
he was saying i don't know but he's
saying that it disgraces what he did he
says he doesn't want that that's
something
i love that dude yeah what did they say
anything about the parents though
no it didn't what's talking to your
parents his name is man
and this is when i go well
that's just that's that's weird gary did
you see that video i know
yeah you said right there i'm always
getting like a movie video
and yes she looks this is a video that
recently
gained a lot of traction on line because
barstool reposted it
this is a goth girl she looks like this
regularly and she has a goth boyfriend
she actually does a transformation video
where she looks like a
ig type girl and the before and after is
when people can't
see this so you don't have to watch the
whole thing but if you keep scrolling
down
it'll show you the before and after
that's it right there
yeah um i was okay
i was hoping for more
[Applause]
that's the boyfriend that's the
boyfriend
she definitely looks better normal he's
so pissed
that's him that's him makeover when he
killed him
she she went wait she went from that to
the yeah just for
oh just for fun just for fun okay she's
probably going to go back to normal
oh she went to goth no she was she was
gone so she hangs out like that with all
that weird [ __ ] on her face
yes and then she went to look like the
regular girl in pink but she doesn't
want to wear that just be the girl on
the right
she went back to the girl she went back
to the guy
yeah she yeah this is like her version
of halloween play dress up for a day and
then go back
yeah um like what does she do for a
living
like where can you work like that uh hot
topic
i set this one in um lebron james
joins the new you know looney tunes
space jam i'm already hearing rumors
it's way better than jordan's
so we just want to bring it to light and
i was trending online
today this morning i'm gonna have to
pass i'm alex uh
he's been doing space jam this has been
news for [ __ ] a hot second did you
see that i
actually did not know did you see the
trailer you didn't know that he was
doing space channel no that they were
fully like doing it
bro here's the whole trailer and then it
was supposed to be it was i thought
originally it was supposed to be blake
griffin
oh really who who said that yeah well
this has been in the works for like for
years seven years yeah and they're like
i didn't know it was like oh yeah
because then last summer it was big
because that he has uh ryan coogler
no they asked the freak the greek freak
uh giannis to be in it and he was like i
don't have time for that [ __ ] yes
damien
he has all the other people yeah but oh
really i was like i'm good man yeah
turned it down he was like man i need to
train yeah they got lavello
let me see the uh trailer is it there's
it on this
webpage uh should be i'll just youtube
it it's already
there we can't watch it on air though
okay
it was just a clip of uh i watched tom
and jerry's the other night with my son
it's [ __ ] good people are hating on
them like it's [ __ ] a cat and a mouse
what do you want
and it's like high def now it's lit
concept trailer yeah
it's not out yet man this one is it was
the one where he was going up
and lebron yeah that one right there
that's what you see a little teaser
it's like a 15-second one okay i guess i
need another space jam
it's gonna be great no that's not it oh
that's it it would that's just a
breakdown huh something like that stupid
breakdown
yeah they don't got yes i don't think
it's anything official yet
look i'm not right there chin it goes
that's him official trailer
yeah a month ago yes it's only like 15
years man lebron is a big dude monstrous
you need to get off his nuts
thank you i've never met a basketball
player without he's tiny hey everyone
it's lebron oh bad actor see this isn't
a trailer
yeah dude we know what space jam is
there it is and get the [ __ ]
out of my face and first of all compared
to jordan
and first of all from bill murray and
that's not even uh that's not even a
real bugs bunny voice i don't like it no
that thing wasn't you know
i was calling it yeah he's not doing a
good impersonation of uh no
the original guy yeah that's donald
trump that's cartoons from my era you
young bucks don't know [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] was weak that tom and jerry's
lit though i'll tell you what's weird is
my son watches uh show on nickelodeon we
watch before bed called sam and cat
okay the one with ariana grande yeah
that's there you go again
uh cat who's young in that is iriana
grande
so he that's his favorite character and
i'm like you know she's a singer
so then we'll watch youtube like oh
there's cat click on that it's like a
different cat now some about sex and
different positions every song
everything's super social [ __ ] me
tonight
yeah she's trying to you know just go
opps to that disney [ __ ]
and it's super i didn't know her music
was like that oh dude yeah last two
albums were very sexual very sexual they
do the newest one is too yeah exactly
her newest one's the most sexual yeah
changing positions for you but it's like
you know it's like
4 35 yeah it is 69. yeah it's tough when
uh
i guess for a parent because like you're
like okay you know
especially when you knew this person
when they were young your kid might be
following and then all of a sudden
they go from hannah montana to like you
know yeah miley cyrus
it's weird so they're like
but then like you know that's this is
what happens this is the sucky part
about like
when people have this perception and
they put you in a box yeah you know
you're like we do have to i need you to
entertain my kids and be
appropriate all the time and she's like
[ __ ] i'm 22. yeah that's also on there
that's on the parent isn't she uh
engaged to get married again
yeah with this because she was with a
real estate agent well this guy did wow
this guy he's this guy slender dms
yeah random real estate agent i know
what i'm saying no good for him because
he hasn't
but had did his business blow up because
that's usually what happens when you
date her
i don't know he's just chilling that's
him right there you're good for him
they look like brother and sister that's
whatever though right there they really
do [ __ ] lannisters
was this gonna work
kevin federline this one
he's born in 195. isn't he crazy can i
do my own headline
yeah yeah please have you seen that
picture of britney spears and her two
teenage sons
no recently
crazy that she has a 14 year old and a
15 year old and i just think to myself
oh my god like
the world just like it's like it's a
flavor she's a straight-up mom now you
know what i mean because didn't she
she's i can't believe how big my boys
have got
recent is it a recent research they just
posted a few days ago oh her ig
free bridge right there yeah the one on
the left oh no no no
can you imagine your mom's britney
spears no no
no because when you're 15. it is on ig
let me go to wrestling real quick
yeah you just saw it right there no it's
not it's a video though oh
i just think it's i just think it's like
wow like this is like really you really
get to see
you know it's like looking at method man
he's like a 50 year old man now
yeah this is weird you know what i mean
like it's how damn wow
she got teenagers imagine all her
all their friends are like your mom's
britney spears
yeah for real i mean imagine how they
must be getting at school like oops
i mean i hope she what if she like was
still trying to relive all the time like
their friends come over and she puts on
her plans
baby one more time and they're like mom
so
so their dad's kevin featherline yeah
yeah yeah
yes wait are they are they twins no uh
there are a few
they're 14 and 15 i believe got it okay
14 and 16. it's something like that
but like it's like it's great it's like
that's their mom yeah
i know it just like literally hit me i'm
like that's their mom it's like it's
like wow we really see how time really
like goes by like people change and
people grow people's like and it's like
i'm like damn she's just a regular ass
mom now yeah you know what i mean
so was uh her uh sister uh jamie oh
really yeah
oh yeah her sister got knocked knocked
out earlier
her child is older than uh uh brittany's
child right now what
is it because she had hers like she was
15 she was 16 when she had her kids
how old was britney britney i think was
25 and she already had a baby about that
i don't know
no yes i'm saying her child her child is
older and britney's
she's a nickelodeon kid too one's 12
years old
[Music]
they stopped the nickelodeon show
because she got pregnant yep it was
called really
so we wanted one zola 101 yeah that's
why they ended it it's off brand
yeah yeah you can't have that yeah you
know what i mean that's off-brand you're
like
the kids at home like what
joey had sex
take her off because parents got to sit
there and be like okay well i mean they
don't want to
cancel lazy we can't have that [ __ ]
they're lazy they don't want to have to
be like they don't want to explain
[ __ ] they just want kids to laugh and
enjoy themselves and be distracted while
they're doing whatever they're doing
you don't want to have to be like what
does this mean
why you put me in this position all
right this one's uh shaquille o'neal
it's it's kind of funny because well two
things first he looks kind of jacked am
i tripping
no he's been working out he looks pretty
big right yeah looks pretty big here and
also he gets like uh slammed into a
table
and i'll show you right here that black
girl she's the wwe
she is she a beast oh is she
[ __ ] and cody you'll see him that's
cody rose right
he actually gets slammed pretty hard and
then right here he's supposed to play
dead right but then he taps him and then
they took the turn
they turned the camera he jabbed all
right
hey get up
the funny part is like he was whisked
off into an ambulance but then when they
checked the ambulance
[ __ ] he disappeared
it's like they did a camera ahead of me
you got out of that office yeah he was
like i can't be looking like
a punk i just killed o'neill
was [ __ ] that little terrible he
[ __ ] his back
[Applause]
at his age i'm pretty sure you didn't
rehearse that you don't practice that
that's like checking out he can't break
his head
right right there oh [ __ ] okay i'm sure
it was somebody that was like
are you sure but how much they do that
kind of [ __ ] dude workaholics
there's a scene where adam was supposed
to run around the corner and tackle me
into some [ __ ]
this was the safety talk you know just
make sure you breathe out
make sure you breathe out but
he can't wait to tackle me dude i was
like god damn i guess
it could have been it did he light you
up yeah
i was adam but he was ray lewis in that
clip yeah
another one yeah yeah elon musk spacex
so they did a prototype rocket that
landed at first and they actually
tweeted out like ah safe landing and
like moments later it exploded on the
launch pad
landing pad so i'll show you the actual
oh wait it explodes and isn't elon
trying to build his own
city in texas
that's that's actual footage yeah thanks
this already looks better than space jam
i don't know if this is the exact one oh
yeah it is
that looks very fast forward it does
let's go here yeah
space down
this them tween out like yeah we did it
everyone celebrate we're ready for
humans
yeah and then boom hold up
wait yeah or did it already explode no
no not yet where is this
there's actually a video with them
talking
awesome oh damn it hold on to show you
oh yeah maybe it's the very first one
but it exploded on the one it actually
landed perfectly but exploded on the
landing pad but they landed where
uh in spacex oh the facility
it's shaped like a dick huh yeah fully
increased the test launch cadence over
the course of the program
and have delivered some of the most
exciting test flights many of us have
seen in a long time
the texas team has several more suburbs
this is the biggest nerd in the world
with number
how long afterwards though um like quite
a while afterwards yeah well you know
you know but the thing is is like what
they're trying to say that's what it's
really i mean what they're trying to do
is like because
they can't you know they that they
waste so much money on the on the all
the stuff that goes up
you know to get them up and then that's
things just break apart they're gone in
space where they come down and it just
ruins
you know millions and millions of
dollars every time so they're working on
something that can they can reuse
and that's that's the first step towards
being able to actually do space flight
you know
yeah there's going to be a few
explosions for sure in the game that's
why they're doing the test right now
yeah yeah i was just dope we just don't
want to see that [ __ ] happen
no did he say when he's trying to build
that city in texas
uh i'll look it up right now it's called
some weird [ __ ] well you know in like
um
in dubai not dubai but like one of those
other neighbors they're trying to make a
green city i think they're still working
on that
a green city yeah green city like they
know that the world can't last forever
in terms of like using fossil fuels
so they're trying to build like some
like their arguments so like we only
have 100 million years left you idiot
i'm like
100 million star bases pretty damn good
i'll take my chance hopefully by then
hopefully by then 100 mil
i think it will still be socially uh you
know don't be sensitive yeah
taylor swift's role model between now
yes star base
star base it says they're trying to get
the per the petition and it's a green
first green city nah nah that's a
different that's no
he wants his own city because he's going
to be attacked it's gonna be like
elon musk rogan chappelle you're gonna
have to be [ __ ] a billionaire to live
there
no i bet it's gonna be lit as [ __ ]
though well
i don't know did you guys see that thing
about the guy that lived
in like space for a year i mean it
actually we're not
ready for this no it aged him yeah like
he he was his body
his density was a lot of it's because
the gravity and all this stuff
oh why because we're not supposed to be
in space you know
it's like it's like so god's like what
the [ __ ]
no stay there it's not good enough for
you huh
so they're trying to but you know you
don't you saw that mars stuff they had
those pictures from mars yeah
i don't know i mean we're like are we 10
years away 20 years away from like
actually doing [ __ ] in mars you know
what's weird like obviously he moved to
taxes save on taxes and he was up mad at
the governor you know and
the lockdowns and the businesses you
know uh tesla
they stayed in san fran like they're
still building the cars out there he
didn't move
oh so they have just built a new
facility there but they still have their
thing here
that was him being like i'm [ __ ] out
of here they're still there uh
of course they're still pretty sure
um that's kind of like i don't know
what's up what are you looking for
i was just looking for it because i and
there's a buddy of mine he he
like oh did this your headline did you
do you know i didn't know i'm saying i
had a guy
come on my podcast and he was like
talking about space and stuff like he
wants to go to mars
yeah i mean it's like those people is
weird i get it i guess the appeal i have
no desire man
i haven't been to thailand you know what
i'm saying
i've never been to italy mars
wait i'm trying to get to the
philippines what i mean
[ __ ] this place is in the united states
most people don't go yeah no says
tesla's last factory still man facing
charge of california spacex is the last
aerospace company still doing
manufacturing california yep
it's still there yeah there's so many
changes that have to happen in
california so we can like
really have good business and commerce
and you know the taxes and all that kind
of stuff that they're doing people just
leaving man it's
the arrogance of california any desire
for you to leave
no i live here you think about it you
know i do now i have been thinking about
it more because i think that things that
have been incorporated into society
because of kovit you know like doing
zoom calls and all that kind of stuff i
don't think that stuff's going to go
away
no because it's so convenient it's so
convenient so it's like hey
all right can i can i live now in
nashville or something oh yeah can i
live in like palm springs now can i live
in like people moving to vegas and that
kind of stuff and i get it
it's like why why are you here what's
the big appeal we can't do anything we
can't go out we can't you know
yeah callan sent me a video because he
was in nashville yesterday he sent me
all these videos of him looking at
houses out there he said come on
nashville man kill i'm like i don't know
la's still the spot man
for right now it's still the [ __ ]
time yeah it really is
well when when because i think when i'm
older i'm moved out there i think it's
going to be like
this when we start changing over from
the covet to regular
well i just like how texas went we're
open it's the same [ __ ] gonna happen
here and all of a sudden telling him i'm
gonna send you this right now
like what am i doing in austin well it's
not slow keep popping last night we went
to a restaurant
and we had like reservations 8 30. it
was so popping we didn't get seated
until like 10 o'clock
oh fair fairfax has been popping up
i waited two [ __ ] hours eating cheese
i remember bringing [ __ ] barbecue
downtown culver city is great guys
that's what it is yeah there have been a
lot of outdoor restaurants
beautiful setting right in front of the
courthouse and all that good stuff all
right yeah they got they got sushi there
no no downtown culver city no i saw it's
cold washington boulevard cole boulevard
okay we need to do a date uh
night this week you're getting you're
out that's all right i'll leave i leave
here
well last time you came you brought a
dude so you're out i bought one white
mike
yeah love white mike white mike got
saucy too yeah
yelling at us and ellen getting all
excited got excited about true detective
yeah don't bring up tv coming back
that season uh what so this is just
what is this what does lucid mean
nuisance
plan to loosen cal that's what what are
we talking about loose like well
you know you go to them he'll be like oh
you can have dinner in your house with
other people like he's
remember they're telling us not to have
thanksgiving yeah yeah or christmas
christmas everyone's like what they
brought to you the recall effort target
and the governor announced today they
had collected 1.9 you need 1.5
i think uh of the two million signatures
they need well
oh okay so you need two million so
they're almost there
keep going down chin yeah here we go so
what's he gonna loosen up with more
vaccines online
and administered um i'm not surprised
that
the people that have been vaccinated are
the highest at risk people
and now all the numbers are going down
yeah
[Laughter]
so all southern california counties are
currently the most restrictive purple
terror
the blueprint and thus are subject to
the tightest economic restrictions
uh okay uh indoor restaurants so they're
here
under the state policy shift now it's
thursday just today right
yeah uh lucian's restricted on business
will be eased once the state distributes
two million vaccine doses hard hit
communities across the state
so when is that so this is expected to
occur in the next two weeks
okay better than nothing well we'll see
9.5 million so that's you know 25
percent of the california population has
gotten uh
the test that kind of a vaccine we'll
see you know we'll see what they open
you know it's not going to be like texas
or florida like oh you're open it's
going to be weird because they're things
like they've been open so they're just
like okay they're gonna have some weird
masks for us to wear now
yeah weird well it is what it is all
right all right guys
that's pretty much it yeah all right
eric we love you man yeah on the road
anywhere else coming up
i'm i actually told my guys book me i'm
ready to get out so
there will be dates coming soon but just
basically i'm on twitch every day still
though
eric griffin gaming on twitch yeah i got
nothing on there now
no dates coming so i didn't put anything
and my website's terrible so if you want
to like help me with my website
i made it myself i mean i'm a one-man
show so you know what i mean like
nothing works look
nothing it is works
you don't have to do this [ __ ] by
yourself man you out there
do something for me let me get a bunch
to help you man i know yeah i still got
my store though
yeah nice i need one of those gaming
tricks man
griffin gaming shirts those are dope you
got my woo-woo face mask
you got the clippers no it's air griffin
gaming with
griffin yeah yeah those are the logo
though just looks like it you know i got
i guess i got a bunch of stuff like that
mario you know yeah my one's really dope
yeah yeah
i made uh chappelle you're off to texas
yep tomorrow night friday
friday night saturday gas company get
them tickets one show each night and
then next week we
are in cleveland thursday friday
saturday
then the following week that is uh march
18th
19th and 20th we're in spokane
washington birthday week all tickets are
sold out so we added a late show
thursday and
early show saturday so uh late show on
thursday and then 4 p.m show on saturday
and actually i'm dumb i forgot about i'm
gonna be in san diego
uh la jolla i'm not at la jolla on the
13. you know what matt rife does that
low-key outside yeah
yeah san diego so make sure you go to
loki outside on
instagram and you can find tickets for
that so that he
they've been keeping comedy alive so
they'd be doing it yeah that's dope man
so i got that show
because my birthday's on the 12th and
the show's on the 13th
it's like it'll be a year last year at
that time i was in tennessee and the
world went crazy right
so here i am out of town again on the
12. doing the damn thing what a damn
thing and then uh
by the time this well when you guys
listen us tomorrow morning friday
morning the thick boy
thickboy.com merch drop the varsity
jackets
and the two hoodies thick boy nation
hoodies drop tomorrow
uh around 9 00 a.m thick boy.com for all
your needs
all right man eric we love you dude
thank you yeah thanks